finally someone else has pudding
deficiency I'm not alone if only I could
find someone else who couldn't ride a
bike actually were numerous people that
said that they could not ride a bike
really I missed that part are you just
lying no there are a lot of people that
she's not anymore and you knocked over
cooter cooter who told you you could fly
come on go yes you are but nevertheless
yeah sorry I just want space away from
Jason because he smells like cooter eNOS
ok so this is the Duke what wasn't just
a Duke I know this is bad when you were
that cat okay so so we had the Duke this
is probably like the cruelest I've seen
bubblegum like she was like a psycho
it's like the episode before it's like
she saw it comes as a little angry I got
badly she's you know she saved the day
cool this was just like dude lady like
okay so Fanny's uh just throwing I guess
potions yeah thrown potions and she's
gonna be surprised yes and mad at
business
oh yeah the balloons it did it did what
I have a different face like before keep
trying to notice but I can never see if
it does from that I don't know to be
honest well but you know it's the snail
right yes okay actually this is one
where the snail is in it twice really
that even knows it once I was too busy
looking at the balloon but okay so you
got throws this bottle accidentally hits
bubblegum in the face and turns her
green and bald and totally psychotic and
is saying how she thinks it's this new
character who she doesn't like and watch
him thrown in the dungeon
but in irons and just like was this
destroy his life because he apparently
ate her pudding which and it's not
referencing anything just literally ate
her footing and I don't actually find
out until like at least halfway through
the Emma's yeah one very important that
just oh he ate her pudding we're not
talking like a pudding cup we're talking
like an entire store house full of
pudding it's like everybody ate all the
chicken fingers in the world listen you
don't know about my condition and I
understand what he's going through okay
when you need the pudding you need the
pudding so yeah good job keeping a
straight face there I just thought on
our joke putting it where you okay no
I'm allergic to you oh okay
yeah Doug deficiency does reaction yes
what am I missing here
I don't know I don't think I gave you
anything to get but anyway so they got
they go to talk to the Duke and who this
really night and the Duchess of nuts
yeah who is also clearly insane and I'm
looking forward to seeing what's a Quay
you're gonna have at the end of this one
by the way Jason cuz I'm so like every
video you have like a segue is that like
the nuts one I I gave you that segue did
you slap that one and you're just like
oh well okay and that's so you have to
somehow find a way to tie in the segue
of the next one here if you haven't done
it already
I'll have to figure something else okay
make it happen
yes mitt make it happen it's oh I just
saw the title the next one that's too
easy it's way too easy
not really yes you can't see how that's
it okay okay if you if you're not able
to get a good segue by the end of this
with that title I'm gonna be very
disappointed okay so I'm just think I'm
not gonna do one eye you're gonna do one
okay okay yeah yeah all right all right
so we got some so goes the Duke is
really nice has this what was that his
son yeah
the son who has a freaking adorable
voice and doesn't want his day to be
taken away put in irons that I like how
he's so nice I even he's like even if
it's not my fault I should be punished
it's just the right thing to do and it's
clearly not but he's just so he doesn't
wanna get anyone's way in which I I like
characters like that and so they go and
they try to put on this fake show to
make it look like you know somehow doing
this to her saved her life with some
fake fighting and then Jake obviously
really had something and yeah at the end
bubblegum finds it in her still very
bitter hard to forgive him even though I
guess I forgive you and she's like you
know I don't believe that pudding story
for a second oh my god I forgot my
newsletter and there's this world who is
angry at Jake because he didn't put his
or her column in his newsletter and then
at the end gets revenge by dressing up
like one of them Royals who fall for the
who fall for the fact that both Finn and
Jake are dressed up like bubblegum and
somehow they both fall for it or they
all fall for it that bubble gum is now
to people they even use the plural
princess Bubblegum's how later episodes
oh okay
so you disagree with everything even
realizing it okay okay but yeah no I
like the likes I like overly kind
characters I like I don't know I just
have a sauce pot for the back I'm a
sucker for him so I really like the Duke
a lot I like that crazy Duchess okay
weird voice she has to it's just like
you know what you like to listen to mine
that's listen to mine now it's a good
design on that too it just I had like
was it peanut ears oh I gotta see nut
had and serve like a big cashew or
something so it's it that was really
great
and
yeah try to think what about Jake with
the hole where the the the Duke is
putting down its his cape for the dog oh
yeah and the nuns go to the Sun and they
hug each other it's like if you give me
enough time I can find a evil reason
behind that maybe I was like the light
you pointed out just like you know you
you take the line I'll take the right
that thing goes left after the guy Jake
a chef I would love to yeah a lot of
that random that you know it is it's not
just randomness it's playful random
things I think that's part of the fun is
that the whole thing is playful the
whole thing is you know don't take it
too seriously let's just have fun with
it yeah you know it's I you know when I
watch this show I I guess as a critical
jerk I always will get something like
you know oh whoa
how did that rate how did that really
work and stuff and I'll find you more
and more it's just sort of fun to like
just go with it you know and it's it's
just it's very easy to go with it in
this show I'm like at first it so threw
me off by all strange random it was by
fine I'm actually really enjoying just
going along with the jokes I don't have
to I don't feel like you know well how
is that joke it's just it's just fun
it's playful yeah it's like when you
watch kids like tell a story or play if
you know you're not gonna say well
structurally speaking little Timmy
that's for you tall had many flaws and
you just kind of enjoy it and it's cute
it's innocent and it's out of it's
almost along the same the same life but
it's also smart as well so I'm liking it
what do you have to say well I feel like
as a woman
I'm already sure every time you open
your mouth it's like Oh George here no
as a girl though and I don't know about
guys but as a girl that whole Princess
Bubblegum thing that's real have you
never heard of people just one look just
one look at someone doesn't matter if
you know the more I thought you meant
the turn green and have your hair God
like getting a
most women don't one that's everything
that's real oh that's in every ten-year
cycle thing no okay have to worry about
really women every ten years women go
bald in green really and bitchy you hide
it well well not the busy part that he
locks me up for the five days yeah good
idea
you have to know it's it's true though I
mean it's it's crazy and it's hilarious
but it is it's true and and I'm glad
they brought it up to see how ridiculous
it is whoa so you do get to a point
where I hate you I don't know you but I
ain't you I just met you but man and and
and that whole thing exactly where she
says you I don't believe what he says
you know I think they're that I think
there's like I mean and men and women
are gonna have the pros and cons I mean
there's it's always gonna be how it is
but I mean there is something do knows
about women that it not all but you know
is that there is sir like this
insecurity about you know how did I come
across or did that person give me a look
into that Brandon it's you know it's
almost like this different language this
language that women speak particularly
with each other I don't find as much it
no I don't find as much with like no I a
woman can't look at a man and be like
you know do you think he gave me a weird
look it's I you should find its with
other women yeah
and yeah we know what's going on in
their heads you know they're all crazy
could you go crazy right yeah no but
there is what I find is that but I find
different different levels of cause like
my wife a lot of times will be like you
know did you know did I say that right I
think I upset at her or him or whatever
did I do this right and I always said no
it's okay you know you didn't do
anything wrong he's like reading into
all this stuff that's not there and I
think if you push that to another level
you know like you know deaf person give
me a dirty look I don't know I think
they did what's wrong on that person I
don't know it's still the same emotion
just taken to an even greater fear so so
you're thinking that this episode is
actually trying to tie into this it's
probably not I mean
I have nothing better to do but sit here
with a bunch of bozos talking you're the
one saying that anyway pioneers women go
clean the ball okay okay
all right sorry I shared a secret with
you with that kind of psyche I'm not
shocked that all women think all women
are crazy I don't like don't look at me
I never liked you I don't like you
anymore fine done I thought you said you
were done
she can't even leave a scene without
laughing it's so bad she is why do we
have her on why-why-why wolves why this
was a mistake
hug me